cañones de agua y gases lacrimógenos en
el paso fronterizo entre belarús y
polonia las fuerzas de seguridad polacas
usaron la fuerza para dispersar a los
miles de migrantes y refugiados que
están intentando cruzar a la unión
europea con las tensiones en su punto
más álgido y habiendo amenazado con
cortar el suministro de gas en el
continente el presidente bielorruso
alexandr lukashenko rebajó este martes
el tono de los últimos días ayer sostuve
una conversación con la canciller
alemana la señora merkel sobre qué temas
hablamos el primer tema fue sobre los
refugiados el ascenso de la situación en
la frontera hemos alcanzado un consenso
de que nadie necesita un escalamiento ni
la unión europea ni belarús y no podemos
permitir que una escalada no importa
cuánto lo deseen algunos lleve a una
confrontación la unión europea acusa al
gobierno de minsk de orquestar la crisis
migratoria como método de presión para
que les sean retiradas las sanciones en
su contra algo que lukashenko niega
el ejército de belarús o me forzó a mí a
todos mis amigos a llegar aquí
cómo llegaste aquí
queríamos cruzar la frontera la frontera
de polonia y el ejército de belarús nos
atrapó cuando nos atraparon nos trajeron
aquí tenemos hasta 4000 personas llevan
más de una semana atrapadas a lo largo
de la frontera en precarias condiciones
la mayoría de los refugiados llegaron a
belarús desde medio oriente en busca de
una vida más digna
franklin extremely complex la situación
evidentemente es compleja y problemática
en extremo podemos ver un enorme
sufrimiento de las personas que quedan
en el limbo es inaceptable lo que está
haciendo belarús y cómo se manipula a la
gente sin vislumbrarse una pronta
solución los solicitantes de asilo
vuelven a ser un arma de presión
política en el seno de la unión europea